we haven't even had time for these clips
this week because it's been so busy uh
donald trump jr suffered a complete and
total meltdown over the fbi search
warrant that was served at mar-a-lago
there are actually dozens of clips of
don jr that have floated around over the
last week but i'm going to look at one
specific clip with you this one is of
junior
sped up as he always is and
the the hypothesis has been this guy's
on uppers
and whether he is or isn't
drug addiction is not funny that's we're
talking about a disease
but even for his own standards he is
particularly hopped up and incoherent
during this viral video which got a
million and a half views
see if you can follow any of what he's
even saying here uh my father says that
he would have given them what they
wanted had they done this but no they
needed the fbi hostage rescue team the
hrt their elite tactical unit and
30-something agents to show up to my
father's home where they then wouldn't
allow or didn't want any lawyer's
presence if you're not watching
the facial expressions are bizarre
the hand motions are frenetic because
i'm sure given all of the examples of
totally above board stuff that the fbi
does that's totally great right like i
don't know if i'm the fbi you want
someone's lawyer there so that there can
be no other claims later on but you know
honestly they don't care
at this point like given all of the
things that they seem to have fabricated
or lied about and all of these things
guess what folks there's exactly zero
equal justice under the law you know
what
pro tip for life this is an ultimate
life hack become a democrat then you can
do whatever you want with no
accountability this guy is out of his
mind
no law legal action they'll just leave
you alone okay but you needed the hrt to
exercise this warrant at mar-a-lago give
me a break right again hillary can
bleach 30 000 emails and take
and
i actually don't know at this point when
they say bleaching emails
uh
this all started because trump seemed to
think
that
i don't even know if i could explain it
trump seemed to think that
there was a there was a software called
i believe the software's called acid
wash and trump at one point genuinely
believed that hillary clinton was acid
washing hard drives like you would do to
a pair of jeans like it was popular in
the late 80s early 90s acid washing and
now it's grown to where they talk about
bleaching emails they haven't said
they've oxicleaned them but that would
be the next thing i genuinely can't tell
what they believe about whether literal
bleach is being used hammers two phones
nothing shady about this folks but
trump's hammering phones that's just the
best ever
imagine bill opens the door to the
basement and hillary's in there with a
mallet
just destroying phones people cooperate
and they still have to show up this way
you know why
because they're there to intimidate you
they're acting
like the fascists
we've been seeing them
be
and of course the fascism is on the
right last few years folks and for all
the democrat talk about republicans
being fascists
these are the guys acting like it give
me a break
okay they wouldn't look at hunter and
deals in china or ukraine or links to
russian oligarchs with links to putin or
links to human trafficking and literally
videotaped evidence of him saying that
the russian mob may have his laptop no
no that was russian disinformation but
we need the hrt team to go to mar-a-lago
it's intimidation folks and the number
one thing we can do to save america and
prevent
us from becoming
the dictatorship that these guys would
like is to drain the swamp and fire all
of the bureaucrats imagine thinking
after everything that's happened over
the last six years at this point
that trump is the person who's going to
be draining the swamp
you you would have to be
in a fantasy world to be able to believe
that so there's the latest from junior
another one of these hopped up
bizarre rants
and it didn't look too much better for
eric trump which we will talk about next
one of our longtime sponsors is monk
pack the keto friendly granola bars and
nut and seed bars i keep these stocked
in my pantry all the time the texture is
great the sweet gooey goodness is
fantastic but each bar has only one gram
of sugar or less just two to three net
carbs and under 150 calories my favorite
lately has been sea salt dark chocolate
people know about my love affair with
dark chocolate but you can also get
other flavors like caramel sea salt
peanut butter dark chocolate and others
then you've got the monk pack granola
bars in flavors like coconut cocoa chip
blueberry almond and honey nut i don't
do keto myself but they are a great
on-the-go snack if you love something
sweet and delicious but without the
sugar which is what i'm going for they
just hit the spot and if you don't love
monk pack as much as i do they'll refund
all of your money just email them my
audience gets 20 off your first purchase
at monkpack.com
when you use the coupon code pacman at
checkout the link is down below